pour nous la vie en tant que
Nords-Africains
l'instant les choses commencent à se
détériorer on n'est plus de la même
façon qu'avant jadis
en français vous cause il vous dit mais
monsieur vous êtes là vous avez du
travail ça me français nous sommes en
chômage vous nous piquez notre boulot
vous voulez votre indépendance et vous
qu'est-ce que vous faites ici maintenant
vous avez des trucs comme ça les enfants
assez souvent et puis ça fait mal
surtout des gens qui ont vécu ici moi
personnellement ça fait 8 ans que je
suis en France et que je vous jure que
vous départ quand tu es venu c'était pas
pareil à la presse quotidienne ne parle
que de nous toujours c'est ça
ce qui fait que ça ça tombe l'opinion
des gens contre nous
on entend toujours un Algérien a tué
j'ai rien volé
maintenant
à tout le monde